ich bin zutiefst beeindruckt wie die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer selbst in
dieser schwärzesten stunde vermocht
haben die hoffnung nicht zu verlieren
und weiter zu kämpfen nicht nur für
irland sondern für uns gemeinsam in
europa diese hoffnung auf freiheit auf
frieden und auf ein leben in demokratie
als teil unserer gemeinsamen
europäischen familie werden wir weiter
kraftvoll unterstützen und zwar solange
ihr uns braucht
das bedeutet ganz konkret du hast es
bereits ausgeführt dass wir die ukraine
weiter mit waffen beliefern werden
weiter mit schweren waffen liefern
werden letzte woche haben wir ein
modernes ortungs radar cobra für die
artillerie geliefert dazu weitere
flugabwehr panzer die gepard sehr bald
wird noch ein modernes flugabwehrsystem
iris t dazu kommen und zwei weitere sind
in der produktion
zudem werden wir schweres gerät zum
aufbau von brücken und auch für die
winterausrüstung auf den weg bringen
aber ich höre natürlich lieber dimitrow
dass ihr getragen von den guten
nachrichten der letzten tage und der
letzten stunde neben weiter diese
unterstützung braucht und deshalb
sprechen wir intensiv innerhalb der
bundesregierung wie wir unsere
unterstützung entlang ihrer bedürfnisse
und bedarfe und der jeweiligen lage
weiter entwickeln können auch die
internationalen waffenlieferungen aber
vor allen dingen der mut und der
kampfeswille der ukrainerin olena hat
dazu geführt dass in den letzten tagen
weitere orte befreit und damit menschen
weiteres leben zurückgegeben werden
konnte aber wir haben jetzt im vorort
von kiew ich habe es mit eigenen augen
gesehen
berlin die märker eben auch erlebt dass
auch wenn panzer zum glück nicht mehr
hier in den vororten rollen oder zum
glück auch an anderen orten eures landes
nicht mehr rollen von russischer seite
dass das nicht automatisch sicherheit
für die menschen vor ort bedeutet denn
an vielen stellen wurden eben diese orte
zurück gelassen mit toten und verletzten
aber auch mit sehr sehr vielen minen wir
waren an einem ort wo wir reden konnten
da sind eigentlich felder da wächst
eigentlich was drauf aber die straßen
dahin sind nach wie vor bemüht
und daher ist es so wichtig dass wir uns
deutlich machen dass auch ein
wiederaufbau auf einem verminten land
nicht funktionieren kann und
entsprechend geht unsere weitere waffen
unterstützung hand in hand mit unserer
unterstützung für entminung weil auch
das habe ich eindringlich vor ort
gesehen
minen die dort von russischer seite
gelegt worden sind sind eben nicht nur
minen auf straßen sondern ganz bewusst
minen um menschen zu töten selbst in
privatwohnungen häusern selbst in
kinderspielzeug wurden russische anti
personen minen versteckt deshalb helfen
wir auch ukrainisches land von dem ihn
zu befreien die die russischen besatzer
hinterlassen haben seit text übrigen
haben wir 84 millionen euro
bereitgestellt damit organisationen wie
hello trust wie handicap international
dabei helfen können diese heimtückischen
todbringenden endlich zu räumen zu gehen
gilt es für uns eben diese hilfe für
menschen weiter auszubauen jetzt auch
mit blick auf den winter du hast es
bereits selber angesprochen die nächsten
monate sind nicht nur entscheidend
militärisch und damit auch mit blick auf
die waffenlieferung die nächsten monate
sind auch entscheidend mit blick auf
wieder aufbau und diese region die
befreit worden sind wo so viel zerstört
ist jetzt einigermaßen winterfest zu
machen
und uns ist daran gelegen ganz konkret
zu helfen deswegen werden wir uns genau
anschauen das was ihr braucht
krankenhäuser schulen die zerstört sind
wo die dächer fehlen die wir in den
nächsten wochen und monaten durch
pragmatische hilfe von deutscher seite
genau dort leben zurückbringen können
und menschen ermöglichen können auch im
winter in ihren dörfern und städten zu
bleiben